excited for this time in life
and i'm excited for what it is we're
doing and uh
and i'm excited that she's in my life
and uh
i i i think she's amazing my kids love
her
it's like it's it's it's a win-win right
now do you ever
see yourself becoming a mom on your own
accord one day
kids have always been on the cards for
me do you guys talk about working
together in other facets
guys well first of all you guys
tell me about the search for smiles
campaign and
i guess what it means to you
so the search the search for smiles
campaign was really cool
they're doing this new search engine um
that everybody can
use as their as their main search engine
and uh
the money that is generated from just
the everyday regular use of that
is donated it seems like now is the
right time for people
after after this pandemic that
don't necessarily have the funds to be
able to donate to causes
uh for them to just be able to get
online and do what it is they normally
do and the donations are made for them
how did you guys get involved with this
together well we've both separately
known amy and scott for a long time
so them knowing us together approached
us and
we bonded over wanting to do good and
create
change and the whole uh passion for
philanthropy when we're getting to know
each other and so the fact that this
came to us
we bonded over that among others among
other things yeah
many other things philanthropies
we're just gonna common no it was
many things but that was one of them and
so it's really cool that this kind of
came to us and we get to
be a part of you know i think bryce said
it best actually it's something that you
can see an
end to you can see real instant change
with what we're doing here at smile
train and that's
that's so cool you know to be able to
see that gratification that change
this campaign is all about bringing
smiles to other people's faces
for you guys what is making you smile so
much right now in your lives
aside from sean and my kids um
just honesty just people being in this
place of like
really accepting uh connection and
really listening to each other and
really
enjoying life and seeing the positives
and things there's really cool things
happening and i'm excited for
this time in life and i'm excited for
what it is we're doing and
uh and i'm excited that she's in my life
and uh i i i think she's amazing my kids
love her
it's like it's it's it's a win-win right
now i can't help but notice how much
you're smiling as you are talking about
sharna and then i can't help but notice
how much sharna
is smiling she's like glowing hearing so
so we talked about this before because
people have been like oh the way she
looks at him like she's
and i think it's i think sharna just has
a much happier face than i do
so i think i disagree with this entirely
okay
okay so then let's agree to disagree so
it's kind of like uh
you know i like i i've known jeremy
renner for a while and he's got one of
those like real serious
faces and it's not because he's
completely serious all the time that's
just the way his face is this is just my
face like this
is i'm super happy but i don't
wear it the same way that she does
that's so funny i will say sharna is a
very happy person you're a very smiley
person
a lot of positive energy coming out of
you which i do love
but it does have to be nice to hear him
speak so highly of you
yeah it's it's it's always beautiful to
hear him say
nice things i think we all have to learn
to take compliments better you know what
i mean and that's something we even say
to each other you're gonna learn to
receive and so
we all have to get used to being
comfortable with that but it is really
cool because i i second it i mirror it
you know i
i love him i love spending time with the
boys they're amazing i love having them
in my life
and i'm really excited that we get to do
things like this with smile train and
and help bring smiles to other people
that makes me smile
knowing that i can make a difference
makes me smile like the way you brought
that all together and you
answered the question you were all so
complimentary that's i like that
you also though you just dropped the l
word is
oh love oh i i totally love her that's
that that's that's without any question
without a doubt that's so sweet it's
been
it has been almost a year i guess for
you guys what what
eight months nine months nine months
something like that who's counting
other than her it's been nine months and
14 days
six hours really 34 seconds 35 seconds
36.
will you guys do anything for the big
one-year anniversary i feel like that's
a big milestone
uh most i'm sure we will i'm not going
to share it with you
because uh that's just that's that's too
much information and you don't
you don't really want to know i want to
know what do you mean
yeah tell me more you'll find out
we had that conversation the other week
though like what is that date like where
do you choose that date like the day you
met the day you kissed like when is that
so yeah
we chose our date but uh i see honestly
eight months has gone
really really fast it feels like the
blink of an eye but i also feel like
i've known him my whole life
so it's it's one of those brian father's
day
is coming up it is coming up i didn't
even i didn't even realize that until
somebody mentioned that they were like
hey
so sunday is father's day yeah
probably swimming and uh jumping on the
trampoline
okay it's yeah it's gonna be it just to
spend time with them and to spend time
with her
and do do that that's that's
uh honestly amazing for me that's
absolutely enough and perfect
yeah and then the next day it's my
birthday yeah
well what do you have planned maybe 21st
again
i don't know what to do that's right
you've known each other for a while
so you can sit with star in a one-on-one
and you can be like hey so what's going
on for your birthday i'm not telling you
anything
i have no idea but i second it's the
same thing as what we would do for
father's day you know yeah just hang out
by the pool and
enjoy family time those are yeah we're
not we're not going to swim for a
birthday
okay but for father's day i'll tell you
that much it's not just going to be
swimming
with the kids okay speaking of pool time
brian you did post the cutest picture of
sharna
and the kids hanging out um swimming
how has it been to watch your kids
really bond with sharna
it's been amazing she's um she's great
with them she really is she's
she's super fun they love they they love
hanging out with her and doing things
and she has a great connection with each
one of them but she's also
uh she just instinctually
sort of knows how to not be a step not
be a step
parent in that way but like really just
bond with them and love them and they
feel really safe with her and it and
it's
it's an amazing connection that they
have and she has it with all three of
them
on their own so she she knows
she really knows what each one likes and
doesn't
and she uh she walks the line really
well
with him i love her amazing kids yeah
i was gonna say not a hard gig you know
what i mean it's not a hard gig
they're really cool little humans you
know and i it's just
becoming good friends with them you know
knowing what they like and playing with
them and having a good time
and they're you know way more about
dinosaurs than you knew before
i know the names of dinosaurs like for a
really big year
i've always loved kids i love you know
teaching kids and i've
worked with kids a lot a lot of my
friends have kids now and i'm obsessed
with them so
uh it's it was really wonderful for me
to be able to connect with them
do you not to get too personal because i
i never like when people
because you know i'm going to shut you
down if you do but go ahead
but have you ever seen it just step
carefully that's all i'm going to say
okay he's got your back yeah you do you
ever
see yourself becoming a mom on your own
accord one day
is that something sure kids have always
been on the cards for me
100 they've always been on the cards for
me um
so you know we'll see what the universe
says
will happen yeah it's just going to
leave that open
brian that wasn't a hard question no of
course of course you notice i didn't say
a word
dancing with our sharna i do have to ask
you bobby bones is getting married will
you be there
when he ties the knot bobby bones is
getting
married it makes me very very excited
for him uh and caitlyn seems absolutely
incredible
we can't make it yeah we so she
she thought it was a certain date and
she was like oh we're gonna be there and
we were all set to go and then it was
like oh no it's a different date
we were planning on being there and i i
look forward to
to meeting bobby for sure he seems like
an awesome guy yeah he's awesome
season 30 will be here before we know it
season
30 oh man i did ask sharna if she would
want you as a partner
because you guys were supposed to be
matched previously yeah
right you explained to me why she would
not want you as a partner
would you want to be her partner though
um partner
i don't yeah i don't no not now i don't
i don't think
i think that's i think that's a weird
uh relationship to try because
she is a pro this is what she does and
so
i'm gonna have to step back and just go
hey teach me everything which is
which is fine but under those conditions
and doing that show and doing what she
does i know
it's like 10 hours of rehearsal a day
and it's like this like
real uh strenuous you know program and
you're you
it takes a lot of practice and a lot of
work and and i worry that
in doing something like that then when
you come home it starts becoming really
hard to separate
right work and home so
um i don't know we talked about
maybe maybe at some point we'll do some
sort of a
dancing something on the show
or if not we'll dance together just for
ourselves we definitely want to dance
with each other but doing dancing i
would totally invite you but again i
don't really know you so
i i i i don't want to give me the answer
but i know you so i'll invite you
do you guys talk about working together
in other facets like would you guys
what what are those conversations i mean
is it a reality show
is it acting together we're both
creative people right so we always have
a million ideas of different things and
that doesn't necessarily mean it's
television as creatives you come up with
different things in all different
avenues
but you know there's also just cool
ideas that we come up with and we vibe
on we're like that would be super
awesome we should totally work on that
yeah you know so it's it's not
necessarily what you think but yes we
always do talk about what we can do
it's fun it's fun because we're both
creative people in very different ways
like we're in completely different
um we have completely different careers
and different
but they they mingle in in some way and
so if we can find ways for them to
naturally coincide and work together
then we do that and we've we've had a
few ideas now that
that are exciting that i think are cool
before i let you guys go
brian what do you hope to teach your
kids about philanthropy and
and giving back as they watch you take
on projects like this
um honestly i i just want them to
have a real good set of moral
values um i can't i can't
make them be people other than the
people that they
are but i want them i i hope
it's always my hope and my intention
that whoever they decide to be
that they that they become that person
and continue to be that person uh
graciously and lovingly and they reach
out to people
and are kind and helpful and
they are people that other people look
at and they go that's
they like being around him as much as i
do yeah
you you seem like such a good dad i
think that's awesome oh thank you
he is an amazing dad i can tell you that
he's one of the best i've
ever known or witnessed he's incredible
[Music]